après un truc qui est intéressant ce que
cette pratique a priori elle est en
opposition à tout ce qui est bien être
tout ce qui est prend du temps pour soi
et settat et en même temps est ce que
cette pratique c'est par réduire son
temps d'écran au maximum et donc
paradoxalement ça s'inscrit bien dans ce
courant de bien-être j'aime bien ce
paradoxe
[Musique]
j'espère que vous allez bien
j'espère que cette année 2020 commence
bien pour vous dans le monde ça peu
complexe dans le monde simple complexe
mais j'espère que voilà pour vous
personnellement ça se passe bien moins
chiant plein déménagement comme pouvait
le voir j'ai pris une petite parenthèse
un petit moment au feng vidéos youtube
parce que vous et moi ce très important
de ne jamais rater la régularité sur
youtube ce qui chose qui me caractérise
je pense on va parler une fontenay et et
qui est sur youtube qui permet de
regarder les
et au plus vite à le faire sur celle là
à ce que le base du coup vous êtes forcé
déjà de l'oréal et +8 pour boire leurs
rêves
est ce normal parce que c'est paradoxal
tout ça est ce qu'on aime aller paradoxe
ici donc voilà on va parler du speed
dating
on va voir qu'est ce que c'est on va
voir
pourquoi on utilise au revoir qu'est ce
que ça dit nous le fait qu'on utilise et
on va voir au sima est géniale qui
viennent à biak ici comment elle
fragilise en fait le combat qu'on veut
[Musique]
à jesse quintessence eux que saint-erme
le spleen wu jing qui est assez récent
cette épopée la raison 2016
un article du washington post et nous
assez récent et art en ségala d'air
s'était pas regarder une vidéo en
continu et plus vite mais c'était en
fait allé au fur et à mesure de la vidéo
j'en reviens à payer plus milieu machin
et voilà voir si ça nous plaît s'il vous
plaît pas à l'ail qu'un ami a pas
longtemps effectivement il ya des gens
ni terry charge des fines et pour savoir
ses films va leur plaire ou pas et alien
passage comme as très bizarre très très
très bizarre
si vous faites ça je ne vous juge pas
mais je comprends pas juge pas un peu
juge un peu ça va en amoureux sujets
seront vos juges aussi justement et le
spleen ou aux jeans un peu ce cas rêve
après le speed reading alors le speed
et on connaît un peu plus les
concourants des concours de vitesse de
lecture md application pour ça et à
plein de conseils de techniques pour
l'égalité et à guam n'annonce un peu
dans cette même veine et aussi le speed
l'isnih ça c'est plus pour les podcasts
sachant que le speed listings ya des
trucs qui sont hyper pratique en général
podcasts et elle ce qu'elle fait c'est
que elle coupe les silences pour aller
plus vite est prêt pour ça
tu es groupe les silences pour aller là
on sur un podcast de fiction c'est naze
mais sur des podcasts conversations des
potters india yoox d'assab de 30 à 100
on n'en est pas encore à phase où on dit
ce qu'on en pense
or trois bus que c'est parfois aussi ce
un choix délibéré du créateur par
exemple beni guil donc tout ce qui fait
par mms
m
mais même m
même
comme vous pouvez voir ces images sont
un petit peu accéléré fait exprès parce
que c'est un peu plus grands l'extra il
ya aussi des craintes h le tube qui le
font qu est claire la vidéo par exemple
le neuf c'est quoi le bitcoin comment ça
fonctionne
à quoi ça sert est-ce que c'est sécurisé
si vous êtes déjà posée au moins une de
ces questions on va y répondre dans sa
nuit à un accord c'est juste qu'ils
parlent vite hockey à nous à s'entasser
du côté créateurs même si c'est très
intéressant aussi de voir comment en
tant que créateur peut balancer une
oeuvre est en fait va être utilisé lui
de manière totalement différente et pas
forcément comme toi tu aimerais là on va
plus à passer du coup de l'audience
[Musique]
alors déjà est-ce qu'on ait beaucoup à
le faire
j'ai fait un sondage sur twitter et 8000
réponse à quel point utilisez-vous la
poussette et de lecture rapide sur
youtube 10% très souvent 20%
régulièrement 55% jamais et 15% il avait
fait pas quoi est on ne voulait pas
répondre je sais pas on finalement ya
quand même beaucoup de monde pas la
majorité mais beaucoup de monde qui
utilisent cette fonction est pourquoi ce
simple déjà parce qu'il ya trop le truc
il ya trop de choses on appelle lui-même
sa déconvenue la plaza heures
on n'a plus sa production menant impute
à des contenus elle ment et à deux trucs
je trouve que le mot contenu est assez
fort en fait pour montrer la perte de
valeur apo surnom
oui je vais donner un chiffre pour
appuyer ce que je dis selon fx networks
aux états unis il y a quatre cent
cinquante cinq séries de fiction qui ont
été produites en 2016 type de
comparaison il y en avait 200 16 en 2010
en six ans en a quasi doublé à trop
trucs et tu rajoute à ça use
je rajoute à ça les podcasts
tu ajoutes à sa ville il ya trop de
trucs et en plus de ça y est ce que
squatter la méta information voyageurs
par exemple game of thrones et par va
voir les articles sur game of thrones
les analyses les critiques les anecdotes
le merchandising genre le fait que tu es
dans un magasin tu vois des trucs game
of thrones d'état en fait si tu as parlé
game of thrones tout dit mais crosgua à
ce que
sinon t'es est hors circuit en fait
c'est monté tout ou maria tout on ne
fait pour cette société ont regagné mode
par exemple même moi sur ma chaîne que
je fais deux vidéos en rapport à guérir
france je fais ni vidéo sur les
philosophies poétique d'un héros france
et une vidéo sur la psychologie de sa
faim personnages et moi même pour être
résultat et vous j'ai sauté la saison 5
et la saison 6 3 un peu chiant nous le
fait que tous n'ont pas à franchement ça
nous pousse à y avait un bus en train de
penser en en dix ans et un effet pervers
en plus parce que quand on est vachement
entre eux
vu qu'on investit énormes montants plus
dedans parce que c'est des scieries 10
eur par saison à peu près tu as envie de
convaincre les autres et tes potes que
ces deux là bas parce que tu peux pas
passer autant pendant un truc qui n'est
pas la balle abauzit je sois jeu
jugeant francs dépensés sainte-adèle que
je me trompe sans à droite tromper un si
je me trompe pas très en pointe car le
montage as vraiment content que on a
l'impression que je critique le v qui
est trop de contenu en fait j + 1 pour
expliquer pourquoi on en vient à speed
run chez ea pas aux raids utiliser mots
beaucoup france au lieu de trop trop
cette gym en valeur ça peut aussi être
extrêmement bénéfique d'avoir plein de
contenus et finalement ça pas le sujet
de cette vidéo au jour mais la vidéo a
évidemment plu en speed world chimie a
la sensation de gagner du temps quelle
sauce yankee mon avis doit libérer et
normandes dopamine je sais pas ça vous
arrive au maroc et ce qui se passe je
sais pas ça vous arrive
cette sensation de genre gagner du temps
quand ça t'arrive tu sens le maître du
monde
un passant de téléporter dans quand donc
plus gros prendre ça donne envie
le succès du micro ondes et enfin c'est
facile à faire je n'y a pas besoin d'une
application supplémentaire à eghezée
passe et amendant le lecteur que ce soit
sur youtube que ce soit peut-être sur
netflix en train d'implanter tester le
truc est sûr qu art de lectra podcast
donc on a plein de bonnes raisons on a
plein
raison le faire j'allais dire bonne
je sais pas mais qu'est ce que ça dit de
nous alors
[Musique]
à ça dit beaucoup de choses et l'art
truc intéressant c'est que ça nous
montre que ce qui nous intéresse
attendant la série on les grandes le
sait c'est sa structure c'est les
grandes lignes c'est l'intrigué
principale son ensemble sa globalité
c'est une très longue liste de synonymes
on va arrêter ici il ya un universitaire
qui s'appelle françois jost qui lui
parle de structuralisme un petit lait
pas le ca structuralisme parce que sinon
adresse c'est vraiment la structure du
récit et au final les acteurs la
réalisation
les petites subtilités ça va moins nous
intéresse encore une fois si l'on
regardé cette vidéo est à pas du tout
c'est pas du tout ce que je sens mais
c'est peut-être parce que vous regardez
pas en haut mettez choses dans leur
contexte on parle de choses graves en
speed watching gracieux qui fait du goût
la dépense pirouette chine corée avec la
mangue pour vous il est à fond dedans et
c'est évidemment ça ne vous concerne pas
tous ne vous concernent pas forcément
esparon sa xsara est ensuite ça peut
aussi penser à ce que disait gilles
fischer stein dans la dictature de
l'urgence et qui date de 2011 et 10
l'urgence insinue sans même que nous le
mesurions dans l'ensemble de nos vies
dans notre vie personnelle
notre vie professionnelle dans notre vie
publique ct y est quasiment dix ans
rendez compte
évidemment on est de plus en plus cela
dans l'urgence insinue d'helmand qu'on
garde les vidéo en accéléré faudra
peut-être prendre le temps ou pas d'air
[Musique]
on va pas se mentir parfois quand il ya
une vidéo qui est le sujet m'intéresse
mais si oui où y'a aucun effort de mise
en scène ce qui compte c'est vraiment le
fond ce qui est dit est la personnalité
qui la raconte
mantas a forcément achats vous je le
passe souvent en accéléré ouais ouais
j'avoue ouais ouais je serai au fouet
après c'est sûr que ça dénature le
contenu voilà mes points 6 effet
constamment en toute honnêteté vis-à-vis
twem je reviens souvent ça y'a aucun
problème le problème c'est quand ça
devient une habitude
et là je doive sortir mon ordinateur
parce que la fin de mon texte
c'est pas synchronisés je reviens plus
de batterie
[Musique]
plus de frais voilà way point qu'à la
batterie c'est plus ce que c'était
après cette série d'événements
dramatiques
je suis revenu parce que pour vous ça
fait quelques secondes mais pour moi
avant ça dure longtemps
voilà donc je disais que le problème
c'est quand ça devient une habitude et
pour ça je vaux lire le passage d'une
interview de marianne wolfe qui est une
neuroscientifique quêter interwievé par
annabelle lorànt deutsch et ouzbeks et
accable laurent qui est venu sur le
meilleur podcast sur l'épisode sur la
meilleure façon de lattre immortel
un belge 2 à lui je te salue avec ma vo
c'est normal
à la base marine wolf ai dit ça sur la
lecture en diagonale mais je pense que
il ya des choses qui s'applique aux
sioux speed watching si nous lisons
diagonale vous n'activer pas les
processus de la lecture profonde
donc vous ne faites pas d'un oeil
critique et ensuite vous ne fournissez
pas d'empathie
nous vous venez de jeter les deux pieds
et de la lecture profonde les gens
croient qu'ils en diagonale pour filtrer
ce qui est vrai mais ils ne réalisent
pas que pluie lisant à canal + leur
circuit entier devient ce cui diagonale
si bien que même quoi il tente une
lecture profonde leur circuit réclame de
la rapidité et je pense que ça peut vrai
ski se passe quand on regarde une vidéo
très vite
alors oui le rythme fait que on a quand
même l'information mais on peuvent avoir
les processus de pensée essentiel qui
nous va mettre d'avoir de la neige
laisse critique de la réflexion et de
l'empathie et au passage si vous
regardez une série en accéléré c'est
peut-être que ces peines 0 ya tellement
de syrie forcément une grosse partie qui
est de la merde impasse frontières
désolé de les poumons en guerre je me
serais prévoir
je plus combien 401 quelques séries en
2016 qui est laid sont toutes folles
dans un possible comme youtube après un
truc intéressant ce que cette pratique a
priori elle est en opposition à tout ce
qui est bien être tout ce qui est prend
du temps pour soi et settat et en même
temps est ce que cette pratique s'est
pas réduire son temps d'écran au maximum
et donc pas seulement ça s'inscrit bien
manceau couronne bien m j'ai donc voilà
peut être moitié moins mais matt et
mieux et être clair vis-à-vis toi même
qu'en maths pour l'info la structure est
pas pour l'ol jules oeuvre et la pisse
chao et surtout attention quand vous
mettez trop vite vous pourriez raté les
informations importantes et justin cette
vidéo à prendre le temps je sens
printemps un petit peu ce sont peut être
les trucs de fin de vidéo convainc
seconde 3,22 de prendre le temps pour le
faire avec moi
ce